you know that there is this crime wave
going on all over the west coast
there is a an organized crime wave where
looters are going in and just robbing
stores cvs walgreens that kind of thing
aoc was just asked about this said well
what you know you're all about
abolishing the police and abolishing
prisons and letting all the criminals
out but there's all this this huge crime
spree going on isn't that a problem and
so aoc's response
is not
to
change her position
her response is not to say oh yeah
you're right okay i guess my ideas
didn't work maybe we shouldn't close all
the prisons
maybe we shouldn't abolish the police
departments her response is also not to
double down and say well it's perfectly
fine it doesn't doesn't matter sure
there's a crime wave but
for my vision of justice that's what we
need to have
her response is just to deny
reality her her response is to just put
her head in the sand put her fingers in
her ears and say la la la la la i can't
hear you i can't hear you
she said quote
a lot of these alligator i don't do a
good aoc impression a lot of these
allegations of organized retail theft
are not actually panning out i believe
it's a walgreens in california cited it
but the data didn't back it up that's
what she's saying it's just it's just
not real it's just fake so it's being
made up by the right right-wing media
echo chamber is it
is it
so
the associated press report the
associated press you know that
infamously right-wing news outlet the
associated no pretty left-wing actually
says quote national retail groups last
month estimated the annual losses to be
in the tens of billions of dollars
from this stuff
just last friday authorities in
the
san francisco bay area conducted what
they described as one of the largest
retail theft busts in california history
they uncovered upwards of eight million
dollars worth of merchandise from cvs
target and walgreens that's just in the
san francisco bay area so you might say
yeah sure retailers are losing billions
but you know it's kind of a weird year
and maybe it's because people aren't
shopping as much well
how do you explain the san francisco
the san francisco cops finding eight
million dollars worth of stolen
merchandise that's not just a guy here
or there going in to get some bread for
his family that is an organized crime
spree that is being that is being done
by gangs of criminals and that is being
encouraged by left-wing politicians when
guests come up to my door this holiday
season this is how i'm going to greet
them i'm going to greet them holding up
these two gigantic knives to show off
the incredible japanese steel that they
are made with kamikoto makes great
japanese steel kitchen knives using more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from japan each knife comes in a
beautiful wooden heavy duty box it makes
sure that the knives are stored safely
and it makes kamikodo a great gift each
kamikoto knife goes through a rigorous
19 step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete the
expert blade smiths forge and shape raw
steel into hardy blades polishing and
sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee i really strongly recommend it
one it makes you look really
intimidating but two it's just terrific
in the kitchen my wife is nuts about
having the best knives for the best
cookware and so we love kamikoto they're
currently having a massive black friday
sale on top of that sale you can get an
additional 50 bucks off any purchase you
make with discount code knowles go to
kamikodo.com knowles use promo code
knowles to save an extra 50 bucks
today
the lib way of solving problems is is to
deny that the problems exist at all
i don't think i'm being hyperbolic here
their way of solving problems is to deny
that they exist at all and hope they go
away or hope that people don't notice
this is true of abortion
the way to solve the problem of abortion
to deal with the problem is to pretend
that a baby isn't a baby we can see the
baby on the sonogram we know it's a baby
we know philosophically it's a baby we
know
scientifically it's a baby but what they
say is nope never mind i
have this ideological vision and so i'm
going to have to deny the reality of
that baby and just not acknowledge it la
la la i can't hear you on crime well
this is what aoc is doing no it's not
it's just not happening it's not real if
you say it's real you're a racist or
whatever it's not happening
education you've got these failing
schools what is what does the left say
nope no problem
get rid of charter schools get rid of
homeschooling yeah there's no there
nothing that you
will do to reform education is
acceptable because there's no problem in
the first place la la la failing schools
people's lives being ruined
transgenderism
a man
pretends to be a woman thinks he's a
woman who wants to be a woman
but he's a man well no he's not la la la
la la we're going to deny that reality
doesn't
it doesn't work nobody benefits
from denying reality
but so much of the left political
program
is to
try to redefine reality right that's the
purpose of political correctness is to
redefine reality by redefining all of
the words
john f kennedy when he says in his
speech his famous speech that was
repeated by countless democrat
politicians some people see things that
are and say why i dream things that
never were and say why not
right where he's actually quoting a play
by george bernard shaw and the line
which kennedy didn't know is the line is
coming from the serpent in the garden of
eden tempting eve he's quoting the devil
he's saying it as though it's
inspirational
some people see reality and accept it
but i i ignore reality and indulge in
fantasy and that's really great that's
what he's saying
speaking of the garden of eden that's
what whitaker chambers said he said
communism
is not the newest political ideology
it's the second oldest began in the
garden of eden when the serpent told ev
ye shall be his gods
you shall be as forget reality
you you in your own mind you will craft
reality doesn't work out very well
hasn't worked out for any of those
people going back to the garden of eden
actually has not worked out very well at
all did you like that clip i'm glad i'm
glad you like that thank you very much
it makes me feel good
please subscribe
ring the bell
make sure you get notifications not just
for the show here on youtube but if you
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast you type in
t-h-e-space
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-space canada w-l-e-s space
s-h-o-w subscribe
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]